Hoy nos trasladamos a uno de los países
más grandes del mundo
de echo, si tenemos en cuenta que no tiene salida
al mar estaríamos hablando del segundo
país más grande en estas condiciones
sólo por detrás de su vecino Kazajistan
hoy en VisualPolitik hablamos de Mongolia
pese a su gran extensión su población apenas
ronda los tres millones de habitantes
haciendo que este país tenga la segunda
menor densidad de población de todo el
mundo sólo por detrás de un país como
Groenlandia.Esta baja densidad puede explicarse debido a su orografía
sus vastos desiertos, sus grandes montañas difíciles de trabajar y casi imposibles
de desarrollar casi la mitad de su
población se localiza en la capital en
UlánBator y gran parte del resto
sigue siendo aún nomada tal y como lo
eran sus antepasados "que las tribus se
pelean como buitres por el cuarto de
secado de una marmota se lucha porque
los recursos naturales son limitados"
la gran dimensión del país se explica por
su historia y es que Mongolia fue
durante siglo y medio una los imperios
más temidos y además fue fundado por
el famoso Gengis Khan "el gran Khan
Gengis Khan" en 1270 se había convertido
ya en el imperio más grande de la
historia formado por territorios
contiguos con una extensión de más de
30 millones de kilómetros cuadrados
más de un quinto de la superficie
terrestre de la tierra
sin embargo el imperio se desquebrajó
debido a la lucha entre los
descendientes de Khan "mi pueblo alimenta
la leyenda de que su gran lider
volverá un día para guiar la
caballería hacia otra sangrienta victoria"
alrededor del s.XVII lo que quedaba de mongolia
fue absorbido por el predecesor de la China
actual la dinastía Xin. A principios del s.XX
con su independencia parte de
mongolia permaneció como nas de la
regiones autónomas de china mongolia
interior y en la actualidad china aloja
más personas de etnia mongola que la
propia mongolia
por otra parte poco después de su
independencia rusia hizo de mongolia
estado satélite de la extinta unión
soviética
de hecho hasta que ésta se extinguiera
no hubo atisbo de democracia alguna en mongolia
pese a su pasado comunista mongolia no
ha dudado en tratar de abrazar el
comercio y acercarse a gigantes
capitalistas como estados unidos
como anécdota hay que decir que Mongolia
mandó tropas tanto a Irak como a
Afganistán y este hecho fue agradecido
por George Bush siendo el primer presidente en
ejercicio de los estados unidos de la historia
que visitara este país
Ha pesar de su glorioso
pasado
mongolia  hoy no está pasando por el mejor
momento su pib per cápita ronda los 4.000
dólares por habitante y en 2005 uno de
cada cinco habitantes vivía con menos
de 1,25 dólares al día
su principal industria exportadora es la
minería y supone el 80 por ciento de sus
exportaciones
mongolia es un país inmensamente rico
en minerales
la riqueza subterránea del país
llegaron atraer a inversores de todo el
mundo
trayendo hace pocos años una ola de
prosperidad a la tierra de gengis khan
en su capital ulan bator crecieron nuevos edificios de oficinas  y boutiques de lujo
sin embargo esa burbuja minera acabo por
explotar y es que las propiedades vacías y
los proyectos sin terminar asolan hoy la
ciudad de ulán bator. En su mejor momento
en 2011 la economía crecía un 17,3 por
ciento casi ocho veces más rápido de
lo que lo hacía el año pasado.Esya
caída es debida fundamentalmente a la
recesión china ya que las 89 por
ciento de las exportaciones totales de
mongolia tienen como destino este país
La recesión china ha afectado al mercado
global de commodities y esta caída de
los precios de las materias primas ha acentuado
además las consecuencias para Mongolia
el no tener conexiones marítimas hace que
el enviar mercancías a otros países
tenga unos costes elevadísimos y esto le
hace de facto dependiente a china sin
embargo no son todos sombras mongolia
mira con optimismo al futuro desde el
pasado diciembre
gracias a un hombre oyu tolgoi un
emplazamiento minero compuesto
principalmente por oro y cobre
y es que tras años de negociaciones con
la empresa riotinto sobre qué porcentaje
de los beneficios debía quedarse el
gobierno mongol se ha llegado un acuerdo
por el que se desarrollará una
inversión de 4.400 millones de dólares
por otra parte hay que decir que la
inversión en otras y minas está
totalmente paralizada no sólo por la
situación de la industria sino porque
tras algunas inspecciones por parte del
gobierno la confianza de los inversores
no abunda precisamente por ello el
gobierno ha decidido abrir otros caminos
para incentivar otros sectores como
el primario o el turismo que permitan
abrir nuevas vías de crecimiento y
superar la dependencia a los minerales
sin embargo no deja de ser sorprendente
que desde enero de este año por ejemplo
los españoles necesitemos un visado para
visitar el país y en poner trabas a lo
que se abre cluster quesero estado el
vídeo que te sale comentarios no ves no
hacerlo y también recordamos como
siempre que podéis suscribiros para
seguir al tanto benestar son los vídeos
un saludo y hasta la próxima